Today, Casual Friday is a day when the conventional
dress codes of most offices are cast aside
in favour of denim jeans, comfortable t-shirts
with movie slogans on them and shirts with
the sleeves rolled up.
But few people realise that this time-honored
tradition of “sticking it to the man”
forcing you to wear a noose around your neck
four days a week (see: Origin of the Neck
Tie) has its origins in a Hawaiian garment
company who were simply trying to find a way
to sell more of their shirts.
In 1962, the Hawaiian Fashion Guild began
pushing to make the iconic Aloha shirt (better
known in the mainland States and abroad as
a Hawaiian shirt) an acceptable piece of business
attire.
The Hawaiian Fashion Guild’s main argument
was that the hot, temperate climate of Hawaii
made conventional business attire uncomfortable
for most workers, also adding that encouraging
the wearing of Aloha shirts would bolster
the Hawaiian garment industry.
The Hawaiian Fashion Guild were inspired,
in part, by a similar campaign in Honolulu
in 1946 which eventually resulted in the creation
of Aloha Week- a week long celebration of
Hawaiian culture that included the wearing
of Aloha shirts.
This celebration not only helped forge a sense
of national identity for post-war Hawaiians,
but also helped kick start the burgeoning
Hawaiian garment industry who were quickly
inundated with many thousands of orders for
these Aloha shirts.
(In the 1990s, due to intense interest in
the event, it was expanded to encompass a
whole month of celebrations and was re-branded
simply as the Aloha Festival.)
Back tot he 1960s, as part of what they dubbed
“Operation Liberation”, the Hawaiian Fashion
Guild sent Aloha shirts to every member of
the Hawaiian Senate and House of Representatives,
and lobbied for them to encourage Hawaiians
to wear the shirts.
After months of this, the Hawaiian government
issued an edict recommending that “the male
populace return to ‘aloha attire’ during
the summer months for the sake of comfort
and in support of the 50th state’s garment
industry.”
But this wasn’t enough for the Hawaiian
Fashion Guild, led by Bill Foster, who began
a new campaign targeting the workplace.
In 1965, they once again began lobbying the
government to allow its employees to wear
Aloha shirts every week on Fridays.
Within a year, people working at businesses
across the state were donning their favourite
Aloha shirts before heading to work every
Friday- “Aloha Friday” was born.
After the introduction of Aloha Friday in
1966, the manufacturers of Aloha shirts quickly
began producing designs with more muted colors
that were less distracting and more suitable
for a day at the office.
This, in turn, saw Aloha shirts become more
and more accepted as a regular every day shirt,
boosting sales even further.
It’s noted that by the early 1970s, most
businesses in the region allowed their workers
to wear Aloha shirts whenever they felt like
it, not just on Fridays.
As a result, Aloha Friday became the day on
which some workers would choose to wear more
flamboyant shirts sporting brighter, more
elaborate designs than typically worn the
rest of the week.
Although Aloha shirts were already a thing
in mainland America at this point, and had
been since the 1940s when American GI’s
serving in the Pacific theatre brought them
back after WW2, the idea of Aloha Friday didn’t
make its way to the mainland until around
the early 1990s, when cash-strapped businesses
affected by a brief recession began looking
for a way to raise employee morale without
spending any money.
The result- “Casual Friday”.
Within a few years, this had spread across
the entire country.
This all brings us to yet another innovative
shift in acceptable business attire thanks
to a marketing campaign by a major clothing
manufacturer- this time Levi’s.
In 1992, Levi’s began a guerrilla marketing
campaign to try to define the idea of “Business
Casual” as they saw fit.
The impetus for this campaign was that, as
companies began introducing “Casual Friday”
and otherwise relaxing their dress codes,
a problem arose.
PR guru Rick Miller, who worked on the Levi’s
campaign, outlined the issue- “We found
when guys shed their coats and ties they really
didn’t know what to wear…
People were showing up in Hawaiian print shirts
or sandals and shorts.
Frankly, there were concerns on the part of
management that work might become too much
fun.”
As such, Levi’s created a brochure called
“A Guide to Casual Businesswear” and sent
it to approximately 25,000 businesses across
the United States.
The brochure was not only helpful to companies
trying to figure out how to define acceptable
casual wear at the work place, but also a
thinly veiled advertisement for Levi’s Dockers-
khaki pants formerly generally only seen on
the golf course.
It worked.
Many businesses used elements from this guide
for their own guidelines for business casual
wear for their employees.
Within a year, men across the country began
turning up for work en masse wearing Dockers.
As happened with Aloha Friday in Hawaii, the
idea of Casual Friday disseminated throughout
the world of business and the idea of “business
casual” being suitable for every day of
the week eventually became the accepted norm
at many companies.
So, in some sense, you could say the reason
many of us reading this can go to work wearing
something other than a suit is, in large part,
because in the 1960s a company in Hawaii really
wanted to boost sales of Aloha shirts.